This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In 2008, psychologist Liz Dunn was invited to go on a vacation. The man she had just started dating and three of his high school buddies wanted to go on a road trip with their girlfriends. They planned to drive an RV from their home in Vancouver to the Arctic Ocean. Liz said yes. It seemed like an adventure. It sounded like fun. It felt romantic. It was a mistake. I would rank it as probably top three worst vacations ever. One by one, the other girlfriends decided that an RV trip to go swimming in the Arctic Ocean was not their idea of a good time. When the RV rolled out of town, it was just Liz
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。2008年，心理学家莉兹·邓恩受邀去度假。她刚开始交往的男友和他的三个高中死党想带着各自的女友去公路旅行。他们计划开一辆房车，从温哥华的家一路开到北冰洋。莉兹答应了。这听起来像是一场冒险。听上去很有趣。感觉很浪漫。但这是一个错误。我把它列为我这辈子经历过的最糟糕的前三大假期之一。其他女友一个接一个地决定，坐房车去北冰洋游泳并不是她们觉得开心的方式。当房车驶离小镇时，车上只有莉兹
and four men who thought they were having the time of their lives. So it was kind of like living through one endless day on this highway that never ended with four Canadian men who were increasingly driving me crazy. with four Canadian men who were increasingly driving me crazy. The road trip led Liz to important insights about human nature. Today, in the latest in our Happiness 2.0 series,
还有四个以为自己正在度过人生中最美好时光的男士。所以这感觉就像是在这条永无止境的高速公路上度过了漫长而又毫无尽头的一天，身边的四个加拿大男人越来越让我抓狂。身边的四个加拿大男人越来越让我抓狂。这次公路旅行让莉兹对人性有了深刻的洞察。今天，在我们“幸福2.0”系列节目的最新一期中，
we revisit our 2020 conversation with Liz Dunn and explore the relationship between memory and happiness. We look at how things that start out fun can turn miserable and how our minds can take miserable experiences and remember them as fun. and the winding road to happiness today on hidden brain. Elizabeth Dahn is a social psychologist at the University of British Columbia. Along with Michael Norton, she is the author of Happy Money, the Science of Happier Spending. Liz told me that at one point in the intonemental journey to the Arctic Ocean, she decided she'd had enough. She tried to escape.
我们再次回顾了2020年与莉兹·邓恩的对话，并探讨了记忆与幸福之间的关系。我们探讨了那些一开始很有趣的事情是如何变得痛苦的，以及我们的大脑如何将痛苦的经历加工并记忆为有趣的回忆。今天，在《隐秘的大脑》中，带你走上通往幸福的曲折之路。伊丽莎白·邓恩是英属哥伦比亚大学的社会心理学家。她与迈克尔·诺顿合著了《幸福金钱：更快乐消费的科学》。莉兹告诉我，在通往北冰洋的这段心理旅程中的某个时刻，她觉得自己受够了。她试图逃跑。
Yeah, I think this is one of my low moments of my life. My phone, my smart phone didn't work there because we were so far north, so I sought out a pay phone. This was shortly after the waste disposal system in the RV had sprung a leak. And I was just like, I am over this vacation. And I called air Canada and I said, how can you get me out of here? And they said, well, we can't get you back to Vancouver in my home, but we could get you to Edmonton. And I was like, can you put that ticket on hold for me? Because at that very moment, all I wanted was to get out of there. Did you actually manage to catch one of those flights? What happened?
是的，我想这是我人生中的低谷时刻之一。我的手机，我的智能手机在那里根本没有信号，因为我们已经到了极北之地，所以我去找了一部公用电话。这发生在房车的废物处理系统发生泄漏后不久。当时我真的觉得，我对这次假期彻底无语了。我给加拿大航空打电话说，你们怎么才能让我离开这里？他们说，嗯，我们没法带你回温哥华我的家，但我们可以带你去埃德蒙顿。我说，你能帮我把这张机票保留一下吗？因为在那一刻，我只想离开那个鬼地方。你真的成功赶上那些航班了吗？后来怎么样了？
You know, by the time I got back from making this phone call, the guys had realized that I was losing it. And they made a plan to try to make things better for me. So one of my friends who's a cancer researcher, like took me aside and he's like, let's have a nice science talk. That will make you feel better. You know, other guys were like, why don't we, why don't we like read women's magazines and talk about them?
你知道的，等我打完电话回来，这几个小伙子已经意识到我快崩溃了。他们开始想办法让我感觉好受一些。于是我的一位身为癌症研究员的朋友把我拉到一边，对我说，咱们来聊聊科学吧。那会让你感觉好点。你知道的，其他小伙子则说，要不我们，要不我们看看女性杂志然后聊聊它们？
Like they had somewhat misguided ideas of what was going to be helpful, but like they were really trying. And so then I was like, okay, and you know, they convinced me like it's almost time to turn around. Like you can do this. And you know, in the end, I did make it through, but I will never go back. When the waste disposal systems sprang a leak, I understand this is how you derived a nickname on the trip. Tell me about that. Yeah, so the guys, nickname me blackwater Liz, blackwater refers to waste disposal in an RV. Let me be clear, I had nothing to do
他们对什么能帮到我有一些误解，但他们真的很努力。然后我说，好吧，而且你知道的，他们说服我，差不多该调头了。你可以做到的。你知道的，最后我确实坚持下来了，但我再也不会去了。当废物处理系统泄漏时，我听说你就是这样在旅行中得了个外号的。能跟我讲讲吗？是的，所以那些小伙子给我取了个外号叫“黑水莉兹”，“黑水”指的是房车里的废物处理系统。我得澄清一下，房车废物处理系统泄漏这事跟我一点关系也没有，但不知为什么，这个外号就扣在我头上，他们到现在还这么叫我。这外号就没甩掉过。那你真的去了吗？你看到北冰洋了吗？你去里面游泳了吗？你到那儿之后做了什么？
with the RV waste disposal system springing a leak, but for whatever reason, like this name stuck to me, and they've still referred to me that way. Like this has not got away. And did you actually go, did you see the Arctic Ocean? Did you go swimming in it? What did you do when you got there? Yeah, so we did when we finally made it to the Arctic Ocean, we did get to go swimming in the Arctic Ocean. We got to see blue gas in the wild.
是的，当我们终于到达北冰洋时，我们确实去北冰洋里游泳了。我们在野外看到了蓝苔原野牛。
So that was, you know, very cool and very special. So here's the question that arises from this whole trip. You were obviously miserable through much of the trip, but looking back on it now, do you sort of think of the trip as being a miserable experience or do you think of it as being a rewarding experience? Well, I think that it makes a good story. And so I appreciate that. Like it's this aspect of my life that was very unique. Not many people have swum in the Arctic Ocean or got into hang out with Blu-Gas in the wild. And so it was this unusual experience that I think contributed to sort of my overall life story.
所以这真的非常酷，也非常特别。那么问题来了，这次旅行引发了这样一个疑问：在旅行的大部分时间里，你显然都过得很痛苦，但现在回想起来，你觉得这次旅行是一段痛苦的经历，还是觉得它是一段很有收获的经历？嗯，我觉得这能编成一个好故事。所以我很感激这一点。这是我生命中非常独特的一段经历。没几个人在北冰洋里游过泳，或者在野外跟蓝苔原野牛近距离接触过。所以这是一段不同寻常的经历，我认为它丰富了我的人生故事。
It also is this really powerful source of bonding for me and those four Canadian men, you know, one of whom I ended up marrying. And so we still, you know, talk about it. It's when one of us is going through a rough time, we pull up pictures from that trip and talk about it. So we really enjoy the memory of it, but I still remember that I was not having a good time while it was happening. So this being this really rich debate in the field of psychology, but also just as people have thought about their own lives,
对于我和那四个加拿大男人来说，这也是一个非常强大的情感纽带来源，你知道的，其中一个人后来成了我的丈夫。所以我们现在仍然会谈论它。每当其中一人经历艰难时期时，我们就会翻出那次旅行的照片并聊起它。所以我们真的很享受关于它的记忆，但我依然记得事情发生时我过得并不开心。因此，这是心理学领域一个非常丰富的辩论议题，同时人们在思考自己的生活时也会想到这一点，
about the value of spending your money on buying things versus buying experiences. And I'm wondering when you think about an experience like your trip to the Arctic Ocean, how does that dovetail or contradict this larger body of research that has looked at the differences between experiences and things? Well, the research on the value of buying experiences really suggests that a lot of the benefit that we get from buying experiences comes after they're over. So one of the great things about experiential purchases
关于把钱花在买东西上与买经历上哪个更有价值。我想知道，当你想到像去北冰洋旅行这样的经历时，这与大量研究经历和物质区别的更广泛研究是如何契合或相矛盾的呢？嗯，关于购买经历的价值的研究确实表明，我们从购买经历中获得的大部分益处都是在它们结束后才显现出来的。所以购买经历的一大好处在于，
is that we can reminisce about them. And I really do enjoy reminiscing about this experience. Of course, many experiences are enjoyable in the moment, but that's not necessarily where the real value of experiential purchases comes from. Instead, the big sort of benefit of experiential purchases over material purchases seems to come after they're over, which to me is pretty interesting because material things stick around. So I am not like a frequent clothes shopper so I literally still have clothing that I had on that trip right like that stuff has stuck around that experience of course is gone it's you know long since over.
我们可以对它们津津乐道、回味无穷。我也确实很享受回味这段经历的过程。当然，许多经历在当下是令人愉悦的，但这不一定是消费体验的真正价值所在。相反，相比于物质消费，消费体验带来的巨大益处似乎是在它们结束后才出现的，这在我看来非常有趣，因为物质实体会一直留存下来。我并不是那种经常买衣服的人，所以我字面意义上还留着我去那次旅行时穿的衣服，对吧，那些东西一直都在。而那段经历当然已经消失了，它早就已经结束了。
But you know it lives in my memory and it turns out memory is a great place to store stuff right so when we store stuff in our closet it it kind of gets outdated, it gets torn up over time. But our memories have this amazing property of being able to make things more positive or at least funnier over time. Because we've retold this story so many times, like just starting to think about it kind of makes me laugh. And so that's kind of the magic of experiential purchases. And so that's kind of the magic of experiential purchases. Perhaps you've noticed the magic of experiential purchases in your own life. Liz cites a study that tracks students going on a three week bike trip across California. During the trip 61% reported the trip was worse than they expected.
但你知道的，它活在我的记忆里，事实证明记忆是储存东西的好地方，对吧？所以当我们把东西存放在衣柜里时，随着时间推移，它们会过时、会破损。但我们的记忆有一个神奇的特性，能够随着时间的推移让事情变得更加积极，或者至少更加滑稽。因为我们把这个故事讲了太多遍了，只要一想起来就会忍不住笑出声来。这就是消费体验的神奇之处。这就是消费体验的神奇之处。也许你在自己的生活中也注意到过消费体验的这种奇妙之处。莉兹引用了一项研究，该研究追踪了学生们在加利福尼亚进行为期三周的自行车旅行的情况。在旅行期间，61%的人表示这次旅行比他们预期的还要糟糕。
But after the trip was over, only 11% of the students said the trip was disappointing. You know, our memories are great at sort of making the best of things. And you know, in my case, the Arctic trip was like so far from the kind of vacation that I would like to take, that it's hard for my mind to completely bridge the giant chasm between like my ideal vacation and that trip. But most other vacations that we take have a much smaller sort of a little gap between
但在旅行结束后，只有11%的学生说这次旅行令人失望。你知道的，我们的记忆很擅长把事情往好的方向想。你知道的，就我而言，北冰洋之旅和我想象的度假方式相差十万八千里，以至于我的大脑很难完全弥合我理想中的假期与那次旅行之间的巨大鸿沟。但我们经历的大多数其他假期，差距要小得多，
what we ideally would have wanted and the way things actually work out. So maybe you go to Hawaii and it rains for several days. But your memory can kind of focus on the days that you were out on the beach and forget about those days, you were stuck in sides or you can think about how it was actually kind of fun, you know, sitting around eating salt and vinegar chips and playing cards. And so when there's a pretty small gap between how we expected to feel and how we actually felt, that's where our minds can kind of jump in and the sort of positive expectations that tend to surround our experiences can actually sort of paint over the little bits of negativity that might have occurred during the experience itself.
也就是我们理想中的期望与实际情况之间有一点小小的差距。所以也许你去夏威夷旅游，结果连下几天雨。但你的记忆可以聚焦于你在海滩上游玩的日子，而忘掉那些你被困在室内的日子，或者你可以回想一下，坐在那里吃着盐醋味薯片、打着牌其实也挺有意思的。所以，当我们期望的感受与实际感受之间的差距相当小时，这正是我们的大脑可以介入的时候，那些往往围绕着我们经历的积极期望，实际上可以粉刷掉在经历本身发生时可能出现的一点点负面情绪。
I'm also struck by the fact that when experiences are strongly negative, in fact when we have, perhaps not traumatic experiences like your trip to the Arctic and had all these downsides, when you look back on it, there is something sweet about it. I mean, you cite the Roman philosopher, Seneca, who said that things that were hard to bear are sweet to remember. And there is some truth in that, isn't there, that once you've been through something really difficult, there's actually a special pleasure that comes from thinking back on it. Absolutely, I mean, one experience that really stands out to me
我也注意到这样一个事实：当经历具有强烈的负面性时，事实上当我们拥有了——也许不像你那次去北冰洋那样具有创伤性的经历，却有着所有这些负面影响——当你回过头来看时，其中会有某种甜蜜的东西。我的意思是，你引用了罗马哲学家塞内加的话，他说“难以忍受的事情回味起来是甜蜜的”。这其中是有一定道理的，不是吗？一旦你经历了一些非常困难的事情，回想起来其实会有一种特殊的快乐。绝对的，我的意思是，有一段经历对我来说真的格外深刻，
is on that Arctic road trip, we did this thing, there's this bar in the Canadian Arctic, you can go to, and you do a shot while having pressed up against your lips, the toe of a dead man, and this is like this classic sour toe cocktail experience that people like to have. And let me tell you, it is not pleasant.
那就是在那次北冰洋公路旅行中，我们做了这样一件事：加拿大北冰洋有一个酒吧，你可以去那里，把一根死人的脚趾贴在嘴唇上，然后干一杯酒，这是人们喜欢体验的经典酸脚趾鸡尾酒。实话实说，这绝对说不上愉快。
Like having a dead toe up against your face, I can't recommend it. But we still have this fun memory of this thing we all did together. And it's fun to sort of remember and reflect on it. And I feel this real connection with the Arctic, because I had this quintessential experience of this sour to cocktail.
把一根死人的脚趾贴在脸上一事，我可不推荐。但我们对大家一起做过的这件事情依然有着美好的回忆。回想起它并反思它是一件很有趣的事。而且我觉得自己与北冰洋有着真正的连结，因为我有过品尝这种酸脚趾鸡尾酒的典型体验。
As a non-Canadian, forgive me for asking what seems like an obvious question, but how does a bar obtain a dead person to get a dead to press up against you while you're having your cocktail? So there's this whole legend surrounding it about the first guy that decided to donate his toe to the bar, but then it became such a tradition and a legacy that now they have a long lineup of toes, people who are waiting for the you know honor of their toe being taken upon their death to be included in this magical cocktail experience. So we're going to talk a little bit later in the conversation about some of the wise
作为非加拿大人，原谅我问一个看似显而易见的问题：酒吧是怎么弄到一个死人的来让他们在喝鸡尾酒时把死人脚趾贴在脸上的呢？关于这个有一个完整的传奇故事，讲的是第一个决定把自己的脚趾捐给酒吧的人，但后来这成了一个传统和传奇，以至于现在排起了一长串脚趾捐赠者，他们都在等待着死后自己的脚趾能被选中并纳入这个神奇鸡尾酒体验中的殊荣。所以我们在接下来的对话中会讨论一些明智的
and brilliant things that Canada does, but I'm actually going to put this one on the other list, Liz, if you don't mind. It doesn't seem to be my cup of tea. But you say that, but then if you experience it, you'll have this great story and you'll remember it fondly. So you've made a case really in the last few minutes of why it's smart to spend money on experiences. That in some ways we anticipate experiences very strongly, we look back on experiences very fondly,
且了不起的加拿大行径，但莉兹，如果你不介意的话，我其实要把这个列入另一份清单。这似乎不是我的菜。但你这么说，不过如果你亲身体验过，你就会有一个绝佳的故事，并且会满怀深情地回忆它。所以在过去的几分钟里，你确实阐述了为什么把钱花在经历上是明智的。在某种程度上，我们对经历充满强烈期待，我们对经历的回忆深情满满，
they give us great stories to tell. I want to spend a moment talking about the potential benefits of spending money on physical objects as well. You want to start a study titled the Unsung Benefits of Material Things, where you analyzed people's satisfactions with material purchases and experiential purchases. What did you find this?
它们给我们提供了很棒的故事来讲述。我想花点时间谈谈把钱花在实物上的潜在好处。你曾着手开展一项名为《物质事物的隐性好处》的研究，在这项研究中，你分析了人们对物质消费和体验消费的满意度。你发现了什么？
Yeah, so this study came about because after I wrote my book Happy Money, and the first chapter was called By Experiences, I gave it out to a bunch of the grad students in my department, and this very smart young grad student named Aaron Readman came to see me, and he's like, you know, I love the book. I think chapter one was wrong. He's like, I think this whole By Experiences recommendation is, you know, bunk. And so I was like, okay, great. Sure. I just published this book and you think the
是的，这项研究的诞生是因为在我写完《幸福金钱》一书后，第一章叫做“购买经历”，我把它发给了我所在部门的一大群研究生，一个名叫亚伦·里德曼的非常聪明的年轻研究生来找我，他说，你知道的，我很喜欢这本书。我觉得第一章写错了。他说，我觉得这个“购买经历”的建议完全是无稽之谈。所以当时我就想，好吧，太棒了。当然啦。我刚出版了这本书，而你觉得第一章完全写错了。好吧，那我们来聊聊这个。所以我们最终合作开展了这项研究。他的洞察是，先前的研究捕捉到了人们对过去的体验消费和过去物质消费的感受，但它们不一定能捕捉到人们在享受有意义的物质和体验消费的当下那一刻的真实感受。所以亚伦非常敬业，他甚至把圣诞假期都贡献出来研究这个问题。于是他进行了这项研究，我们要求人们告诉我们他们在圣诞节收到的一件物质物品或是一段经历。然后他开始发短信
first chapter is completely wrong. Like, let's, let's, let's talk about that. So we ended up teaming up to, to conduct the study. And his, his insight was that previous studies had captured how people felt about their past experiential purchases and their past material purchases, but they hadn't necessarily captured people right in the moment as they were enjoying, you know, meaningful material and experiential purchases. So Aaron was really dedicated and he actually devoted his Christmas vacation to studying this issue. So he connected this study where we asked people to tell us about either a material thing or an experience that they had received for Christmas. And he began texting
从圣诞节当天开始，每天三到五次，连续好多天。而且他在两周内每天都进行跟踪回访。他发现的一点是——嗯，他每天都进行跟踪回访，持续了两周。其中一个他发现的现象是，人们实际上从物质事物中获得了更频繁的快乐。所以物质事物有一个被忽视的好处，那就是它们总是陪伴在左右。例如，我有一件我很喜欢的皮夹克。每次我穿上它，我都觉得稍微快乐了一点。你知道的，我不是那种欣喜若狂，只是稍微开心了一点。正是这种日常生活中微小的短暂快乐提升，被先前的研究所忽视了。这就是我们在研究中看到的，物质事物确实提供了这种微小但频繁的幸福感提升。相比之下，经历在某些方面可能会带给你最高峰值的体验，对吧？换句话说，它们的发生频率可能较低，但峰值会高得多。没错。
them three to five times a day, every single day starting on Christmas day. And he followed up with them, you know, every single day for two weeks. And one of the things that he discovered was that them, you know, every single day for two weeks. And one of the things that he discovered was that people did actually get more frequent happiness from material things. So material things had this unsung benefit, which was that, you know, they are kind of always around. So for example, I have a leather jacket that I really like. And every time I put it on, I kind of feel a little bit happier. You know, I'm not like freaking out. I'm just like a little bit happier. It was that sort of little small boost
因此，当我们询问人们所经历的幸福感强度时，我们发现这些圣诞节的体验礼物给人们带来了更大的峰值、更强烈的快乐爆发，而物质事物则给人们带来了一种剂量较低、但更频繁的幸福感。从这个意义上说，你可能会觉得这就像是两种口味冰淇淋。经历就像是意式冰淇淋，带来强烈的情绪爆发，但随后就消失了。而另一方面，物质事物更像是一大桶冷冻酸奶，它们在任何单个时刻可能都没有那么惊艳，但你可以享用好一阵子。
in momentary happiness that these previous studies had kind of overlooked. And so that's what we saw in our study was that material things do provide this small but frequent boost to happiness. And in contrast, experiences in some ways might give you the tallest peaks, right? In other words, they might be less frequent, but the peaks are going to be much higher. Exactly.
所以从这个意义上讲，我觉得物质事物可能有点名誉受损。所以也许与其说“经历让你快乐，而物质不能”，不如说“经历带给你——正如你所说——一种不同类型的快乐”更为明智。它们给你带来更多期待、更美好的回忆。但通常在当下的瞬间，物质可以带给你许多小小的快乐时刻。关于幸福的另一个问题是，你更喜欢哪种幸福？
So when we asked people about the intensity of happiness that they were experiencing, we saw that these experiential Christmas gifts gave people much bigger peaks, much more intense bursts of happiness, whereas the material things gave people this sort of lower dose, but more frequent feeling of happiness. So in that sense, you might think of it as like two flavors of ice cream. You know, experiences are like gelato with this intense burst of happiness, but then it's gone. And then on the flip side, you know, material things are more like a big thing of froyo, where they're not as amazing in any one moment, but you can have it for a while.
没错。那么，你是想要物质事物可能带来的那种低水平的满足感，还是想要从经历中获得的那些快乐爆发？现在，根据我目前所说的一切，经历和物质事物似乎处于同等地位，这很大程度上取决于你想要什么风味的幸福。但事实上，我们在圣诞节六周后对同一批参与者进行了跟踪回访。
And so in that sense, I think material things maybe got a little bit of a bad rap. So maybe instead of saying that experiences make you happy and things don't, it might be why is it to say that experiences give you, as you say, a different kind of happiness? They give you more anticipation, better memories. But often, in the moment, things can give you many small moments of pleasure. And part of the question about happiness is what kind of happiness do you prefer?
到了这个时候，他们肯定已经对我们厌烦透顶了，但他们还是为我们填写了另一份调查问卷。而且，你知道的，我们询问了他们当时对圣诞礼物的感受。我们发现，在圣诞节六周后，人们对体验礼物的满意度明显高于对物质礼物的满意度。这让我们觉得非常有趣，
Exactly. So do you want those low level moments of contentment that material things might provide or do you want these bursts of joy that you might get from experiences. Now, from what I've said so far, it does seem like experiences and material things are kind of on an equal playing field, and it sort of depends what flavor of happiness you want. But we actually also followed up with our same participants six weeks after Christmas.
因为这再次表明，尽管在那时体验消费或体验礼物本质上已经结束了——大多数人已经享受过他们的水疗日、去看了冰球比赛，或者无论他们在圣诞节收到了什么——但在圣诞节六周后，他们实际上对这些经历感到更加满意，相比于那些收到物质礼物的人。所以从这个角度来看，我觉得亚伦是对的，这位研究生是对的，买经历的建议可能有点过于简单了，但我感觉自己还是赢到了最后，我想说：“是的，但到了六周后，经历依然胜出。”当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么追求幸福会感觉像是在跑步机上奔跑，以及如何摆脱它。您正在收听的是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
By this point, they must have been really sick of us, but they still filled out another survey for us. And, you know, we asked them how they were feeling about their Christmas gift at that point. And what we found was that six weeks after Christmas, people were significantly more satisfied with their experiential gift than people were with material gifts. And so this was really interesting to us,
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。你有没有发现，你的挚友和亲人在面对陌生人或泛泛之交时，表现得简直就像是完全不同的人？也许是你的母亲，吃早餐时对麦片抱怨连连，10分钟后却能在Zoom会议上和同事说说笑笑。或者是你的幼儿，在家里正处于崩溃的边缘，而当你把他带到日托中心时，他却变成了一个完美的天使。莉兹·邓恩在读研究生时，第一次注意到类似的现象。她当时有一个男友叫本杰明，他做过的一件事让她觉得相当恼火。所以每当本杰明心情有点糟糕时，他就会来找我——他交往很久的女友，然后表现得有点急躁和暴躁。但如果我们碰巧遇到了某个泛泛之交甚至是个陌生人，本杰明就会立刻振作起来，
because again, it suggests even though the experiential purchases or experiential gifts in essence were gone by that point, like most people had already enjoyed their spa day or gone to the hockey game or whatever it was that they'd received for Christmas, but they actually felt more satisfied with it six weeks after Christmas compared to people who had gotten these material gifts. So in that way, I think Aaron was right, I mean, grads who was right, that like the advice to buy experiences might be a little too simple, but I feel like I kind of have a last laugh and saying, yeah, but by six weeks afterward,
表现得十分随和愉快，正如社会规范所要求的那样。我注意到的是，在此之后，他的心情实际上会好很多。由于他自己表现出的那种随和、快乐的行为，他的心情也随之变好了。因此，我开始琢磨，这只是本杰明身上某种奇怪的怪癖吗？还是这属于人类行为模式的一部分？于是，我决定把大约一百对恋爱中的情侣请进实验室，试图弄清真相
like, experience is still win. When we come back, why the pursuit of happiness can feel like being on a treadmill and how to get off it. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever noticed that your loved ones can seem like totally different people when they are around strangers or acquaintances? Maybe it's your mom, so grumpy over her breakfast cereal,
背后的原因。莉兹录下了其中一些人与真实伴侣交谈的录音，以及另一些人与陌生人交谈的录音。这里有一段情侣交谈的剪辑。那是你偶遇他们的地方吗？不。其实不是。今天我丢了55块钱怎么样？这里是一段两个陌生人交谈的剪辑。你多大了？
chatting and laughing with colleagues 10 minutes later on Zoom. Or your toddler, on the brink of a meltdown at home, who becomes a perfect angel when you bring him into daycare. Liz Dahn first noticed something similar when she was in grad school. She had a boyfriend, Benjamin, and he did something that she found pretty annoying. So when Benjamin was in a little bit of a bad mood, he would come to me, his longtime girlfriend, and he would act kind of cranky and grumpy. But if we happen to run into random acquaintance or even a stranger, Benjamin would perk right up,
七个月。你多大了？才一岁。一岁？一岁？我才一岁。对。对，我们在同一个宿舍。令我瞩目的是，当情侣在交谈时，你会听到这种低沉的、
acting all pleasant and cheerful as social norms demand. And what I noticed is that afterward, he would actually be in a much better mood. As a result of his own sort of pleasant, cheerful behavior, he would get himself into a better mood. And so, I started to wonder, is this just some weird quirky thing about Benjamin? or is this part of the way that humans behave? And so, I decided to bring in about a hundred romantic couples into the lab to try to get to the bottom of
带点轻微暴躁语调的声音。而当陌生人在交谈时，他们的语调非常欢快、积极且充满活力，这正是我们所期待的。因此，至少在北美，有一种强烈的社会需求，即在与刚认识或不太熟的人交谈时，要表现得愉快和开朗。所以在我们的研究中看到的是，当人们进行这种积极的自我呈现——在不认识的人面前表现得随和开朗时，这实际上对他们自身的情绪有益，而这种益处是他们自己似乎无法预见的。当我们为了别人的利益而表现得随和
this. Liz recorded some of the people chatting with their actual partners, and some chatting with a stranger. Here's a clip of two people who are in a relationship. Is that where you run into them? No. It's not really. What about today I lost 55? And here's a clip of two strangers. How old are you?
和开朗时，它为我们的情绪提供了一种意想不到的提升。当我们为了别人的利益而表现得随和和开朗时。我们倾向于把最好的一面展现给陌生人，而不是朝夕相处的生活伴侣，这个事实确实很悲哀。但事实证明，我们理所当然对待的不只是我们的伴侣。我们在生活中的几乎所有事情上都这么做。熟悉感就算不会滋生轻蔑，至少也会滋生某种程度的冷漠。莉兹，你能谈谈这个观点吗？
Seven months. How old are you? Just a year. A year? A year? I'm just a year. Yeah. Yeah, we're in the same dorm. What stands out to me is that when the romantic couple is talking, you hear this sort of low-level,
是的，这是所有幸福研究中最核心的观点之一，那就是无论我们拥有什么，我们最终都会习惯它。所以无论我们的生活有多棒，或者有什么美好的事物进入我们的生活，
sort of mildly cranky kind of tone. Whereas when the strangers are talking, they have this very cheerful, positive upbeat lilt, which is what we expect. So in North America, at least there's this strong demand to act pleasant and cheerful when you're talking to someone that you haven't met before or don't know well. And so what we see in our study is that when people engage in this positive self-presentation, acting all sort of pleasant and cheerful around someone that you don't know, it actually has benefits for their own mood in a way that they themselves don't seem to foresee. It provides this unexpected boost to our moods when we just act pleasant
随着时间的推移，我们都会习惯它们。它们带给我们的快乐也逐渐消退。这有时被称为“享乐适应 treadmill（跑步机）”。能跟我讲讲这个词的起源吗？这个词究竟想要传达什么意思？是的，“享乐跑步机”是一个多么悲哀的词啊，对吧？它传达了一种我们被困住的想法。无论我们多么努力地想要变得更快乐，我们都做不到。我们就像是在一台跑步机上，无论怎么跑，最终总会回到原点。所以，拼命奔跑、更努力地工作以求获得快乐，其实都是徒劳无功的。因此，这里的跑步机隐喻，当然是指你在奔跑，但
and cheerful for the benefit of somebody else. when we just act pleasant and cheerful for the benefit of somebody else. The fact that we tend to present our best sides to strangers rather than to people who inhabit our lives is very sad. But it turns out it's not just our partners that we take for granted. We do this with nearly everything in our lives. Familiarity breeds, if not contempt, at least a certain amount of indifference. Can you talk about this idea, Liz? Yeah, so this is one of the most important ideas across all of happiness research, which is that whatever we have, we tend to get used to it. So no matter how awesome our lives might be or what wonderful things come into our lives,
尽管你在奔跑，你其实依然留在原地。换句话说，它并没有改变你的幸福感，尽管你觉得自己正在做那些应该让你更快乐的事情。所以你和其他人一直在寻找方法来对抗这种心理现象，即享乐适应的现象。你们从一个
we tend to get used to them over time. And the pleasure that they provide gradually diminishes. This has sometimes been called the hedonic treadmill. Give me a sense of the origin of that phrase. What is that phrase trying to communicate? Yeah, so the hedonic treadmill is such a sad phrase, right? It conveys this idea that we're sort of stuck. No matter how hard we try to get happier, we can't. We're kind of on this treadmill where we always end up kind of back where we started. So try to run faster, work harder to get happier, and it doesn't do any good. So the metaphor of the treadmill here, of course, is the idea that you're running, but it's still
麦当娜的营销诡计中获得了灵感。这里有一段麦当劳顾客谈论“麦肋堡（McRib）”的剪辑。我不是麦肋堡。我太棒了。关键是，对吧？这太棒了。这是有史以来最棒的东西。
you're staying in place even as you're running. In other words, it's not changing how happy you're feeling, even though it feels like you're doing things that should make you happier. So you and others have thought of ways to fight this psychological phenomenon, this phenomenon of the hedonic treadmill. And you've drawn inspiration from a marketing trick
你为什么要把它下架？我不喜欢它。我需要它。但它不会一直留在这里。莉兹，这到底是怎么回事？我需要它，但它不会一直留在这里。莉兹，这到底是怎么回事？所以“麦肋堡”是麦当劳的一款三明治，只在限定时间内供应。
by McDonald's. Here's a clip of a McDonald's customer talking about the Macribe. I'm not a Macribe. I'm so good. Here's the thing, right? It's amazing. It's the best thing ever made.
因此，在其人气达到顶峰时，麦当劳会将其从菜单上撤下。乍一看，如果一款产品卖得很好，这似乎有点违反直觉，你本以为会想继续提供它。但事实上，通过将它撤下，麦当劳实际上可以让它变得更加抢手。这与享乐跑步机的概念以及如何克服它的心理学洞察有什么联系？
Why would you get rid of it? I don't like it. I need it. But it's not gonna stick around. What's going on here, Liz? I need it, but it's not going to stick around. What's going on here, Liz? So the McRib is a McDonald's sandwich that is only available for a limited time.
嗯，事实证明，对抗享乐适应或摆脱享乐跑步机的一种方法，就是稍微剥夺一下我们自己。也就是不要总是源源不断地接触我们喜欢的东西。一方面，幸福的秘方似乎应该是让我们所有喜欢的东西都随时随地唾手可得。但事实上，这种做法导致的往往是巨大的享乐适应，我们会对
So at the height of its popularity, McDonald's will pull it off the menu, which at first glance seems a bit counterintuitive if you have a product that's selling really well, you'd think you'd wanna keep it available. But in fact, by yanking it away, McDonald's can actually make it more desirable. And how is this connected to the idea of the hedonic treadmill and the psychological insight about how to overcome it?
喜欢的东西习以为常，并从中获得的快乐大不如前。因此，在我的某些研究中，我们发现实际上将某些东西从人们的生活中拿走一段时间，可以增强他们再次享受这些东西的能力。你从人们身边拿走过什么样的事情，来观察它对他们产生的影响？所以在我的实验室里，我们买了很多巧克力。巧克力是一种相当不错且可靠的快乐源泉。我们的大多数研究参与者真的很喜欢巧克力，并且从吃巧克力中获得乐趣。因此在我们开展的一项研究中，我们将人们请进实验室，让他们吃了一小块巧克力。然后我们让其中一组学生带走一大袋巧克力，并要求他们在接下来的一个星期里，尽可能多地舒适享用。
Well, it turns out that one way to fight hedonic adaptation or get off the hedonic treadmill is to deprive ourselves a little bit. So to not have constant access to the things that we like. So on the one hand, it seems like the recipe for happiness should be to have all the things that we like abundantly available to us all the time. But in fact, what that's a recipe for is massive hedonic adaptation, where we just get used
与此同时，我们要求另一组学生在整整一周内克制自己，不要吃任何巧克力。最后，我们让第三组学生保持原样，没有任何关于巧克力的特殊指令。一周后，我们把所有人重新请回实验室，再次让他们吃了一些巧克力。现在，我们从大多数样本中看到的是，人们对巧克力的喜爱程度明显
to the things that we like and no longer derive as much pleasure from them. So in some of my research, what we've discovered is that actually taking things away from people for a period of time can increase their capacity to enjoy those things. What kind of things have you taken away from people to see the effects it has on them? So in my lab we buy a lot of chocolate. Chocolate is a pretty good reliable source of happiness. Most of our research participants really like chocolate and get enjoyment from eating it. So in one study that we ran, we brought people into the lab and asked them to eat a little bit of chocolate. And then we sent one group of students away with a big bag of chocolate and asked them to eat as much as they comfortably could over the ensuing week.
比第一次时要低。这个小小的发现恰好捕捉到了人类体验中悲哀的现实，那就是我们拥有某样东西越多，我们就越不珍惜它。但有一群人，他们第二次对巧克力的喜爱程度至少和第一次一样高，这就是那些在期间被要求戒掉巧克力的人。因此，这表明从我们喜欢的事物中抽身短暂告别，实际上可以重塑我们欣赏它们的能力。
Meanwhile we asked another group of students to please refrain from eating any chocolate for a whole week. And finally we just left this third group of students without any special chocolate-related instructions. Then we brought everybody back into the lab a week later, and once again, we had them eat some chocolate. Now, what we see across most of the sample is that people enjoyed the chocolate significantly
所以有些人——其中许多人当然是在硅谷——正在把这个想法推向逻辑上的极致。如果稀缺性能产生更大的快乐，那就人为制造稀缺。听听这段关于某人谈论“多巴胺禁食”的剪辑。规则是没有快乐。任何你觉得快乐的事情，都不被允许做。例子有，电子产品，没有电子产品，没有电脑，没有iPod，没有手机，没有食物，没有咖啡，没有茶，没有果汁，没有果汁，不，只有水。
less the second time than they had the first time. And this little tiny finding kind of captures the sad reality of the human experience, which is that the more we have something, the less we tend to appreciate it. But there was one group of people that enjoyed the chocolate, at least as much the second time as they had the first, and this was the people who had been asked to give up the chocolate in between. So what this suggests is that taking a break from things that we enjoy can actually sort of renew our capacity to appreciate them.
换句话说，莉兹，所有你以为会让你快乐的事情实际上让你不快乐，而所有你以为会让你不快乐的事情实际上让你快乐。是的，我的意思是，我想说的是，戒掉所有这些事情——尽管对我来说，戒咖啡听起来太可怕了——但在禁绝它们的期间，戒掉这些东西可能并不会让你感到快乐。所以我并不是在争辩说，无欲无求有什么真正让人愉悦的地方，对吧？我并不是在争辩说一无所有有什么真正让人愉悦的地方。对吧？
So there are people, many of them of course in Silicon Valley who are taking this idea to its logical conclusion. If scarcity can produce greater happiness, let's engineer scarcity. Take a listen to this clip about someone talking about a dopamine fast. The rules are no pleasure. Anything you find pleasurable, you're not allowed to do. Examples, electronics, no electronics, no computers, no iPods, no phones, no food, no coffee, no teas, no juice, no juice, no, just water.
相反，这里的核心想法是，我们可以通过暂时告别我们喜欢的事物，来稍微重启我们的幸福系统。我并不是主张我们所有人都应该搬进树林里，放弃生活中的每一种快乐。那可不是通往幸福的秘方，但你知道的，通往幸福的秘方确实包括弄清楚如何稍微重置一下我们自己，这样我们就能重新欣赏那些我们已经开始视为理所当然的事物。所以这意味着，你知道的，我认为异地恋
In other words, Liz, everything you thought would make you happy actually makes you unhappy and everything you thought would make you unhappy actually makes you happy. Yeah, I mean, I would say taking a break from all of those things, as terrible as it sounds to me to take a break from coffee, taking a break from these things probably won't make you happy while you're abstaining from them. So I'm not arguing that, you know, there's something really pleasurable about having nothing, right? not arguing that there's something really pleasurable about having nothing. Right?
在这个层面上可能很有趣，因为你知道，你会经历那些无法与浪漫伴侣在一起的空白期。所以我的丈夫曾去非洲待了六个月，我真的很想念他。即便我们现在整天腻在一起，我依然能感受到那种情绪，仅仅回想起那段我们分离的漫长时期，就能让我更加珍惜他现在时刻陪伴在我身边的状态。经历是不是更不容易引发享乐跑步机，
Instead, the idea is that we can kind of restart our happiness systems a little bit by taking a break from the things that we like. I would not advocate that we should all move into the woods and give up every kind of pleasure in life. That's not the recipe for happiness, but you know the recipe for happiness does involve figuring out how to reset ourselves a little bit so that we appreciate the things that we've started to take for granted. And so that can mean you know I think long distance relationships are
恰恰是因为它们本身更难得？你不可能每个周末都去北极圈，因此投资于经历而不是物质，会自动迫使你陷入一种稀缺状态，而当你考虑物质消费或物质物品时，这种状态是不存在的。绝对是的，因为关于经历有趣的一点在于它们感觉是独一无二的。我的北冰洋公路旅行对我的感觉而言是非常独特的，但即使是去——比如，去看一场布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀的演唱会，就像我在读研究生时做的那样——显然布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀在世界各地演出。有非常多的人看过他的演出，但对我而言，那场演唱会的感觉是，哦，那场演出
potentially interesting in that way because you know you have these breaks where you're not able to be with your romantic partner. So my husband went to Africa for six months and I really missed him and I can still sort of channel that, even though we're around each other all the time, even just thinking back to that long period where we were separated can help me appreciate that he's around all the time now. Is it possible that experiences are less likely to produce the hedonic treadmill precisely
真的很特别，而且我再也不会有那种体验了。因此，我们的经历具有了独一无二的属性，这使得我们很难对它们产生适应。而物质事物，则很容易进行比较。你知道的，你完全可以拿更好的东西来替换它们。因此，物质事物可能比经历更容易受到享乐跑步机这个问题的困扰。
because they are in fact rarer? You can't go to the Arctic Circle every weekend, so investing in experiences rather than things automatically forces you into a form of scarcity that you don't have when you are thinking about material purchases or material objects. Absolutely, because one of the things that's interesting about experience is that they feel unique. My Arctic road trip feels very unique to me, but even going to, like, say, a spring steam concert, like I did in grad school, obviously Bruce Springsteen plays all over the world. Many, many people have seen him, but that concert, for me, feels like, oh, well, the hat was
花时间去回味我们过去的经历以及当前所有可用的经历，是在极其艰难时期最大化幸福感的一种方式。接下来，我们将探讨在许多人经历艰难困苦的时刻，另一种提升幸福感的方法。请继续收听。您正在收听的是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
really special, and I'm never him, but that concert for me feels like, oh, well, that was really special. And I'm never going to have that exact experience again. And so our experiences take on this property of uniqueness that makes it harder to adapt to them. Whereas material things, they're really easy to compare. You know you could replace them with something probably even better. And so material things may be more subject to this problem of the hedonic treadmill than
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。谁说金钱买不到快乐，那是他不知道该去哪里买。你可能听过关于金钱与幸福关系的这句话的各种版本。哲学家、小说家和电视编剧们都曾纠结于这样一个问题：我们是否能用钱买到极乐。多年来，研究人员一直试图检验消费与满足感之间的关系。他们采用的方法之一是给志愿者一些钱，并告诉他们把钱花在自己身上还是别人身上。社会心理学家莉兹·邓恩表示，不出所料，大多数人预期把钱花在自己身上会收获更多快乐。
experiences. Taking time to save up the experiences we've had in the past and whatever experiences are currently available is one way to maximize happiness during a very difficult time. Coming up, we look at another way to increase well-being at a moment when many people are experiencing hardship. Stay with us. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而且，你知道的，这挺有趣的，因为我确实收到过人们的来信，上面写着：“为什么科学家们非要跑来做这种研究呢？比如这种帮助别人的想法在《圣经》里就有，或者我妈妈从小就这么告诉我。”但有趣的是，当你把钱引入这个画面时，人们就是没有意识到他们口袋里那张20美元的钞票，花在别人身上可能比花在自己身上更好。所以几年前你正坐着和会计核对你的税务，
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Whoever said money can't buy happiness didn't know where to shop. You've probably heard some version of this quote about the relationship between money and happiness. Philosophers, novelists and TV writers have all wrestled with the question of whether we can buy our way to bliss. Over the years, researchers have tried to test the relationship between spending and contentment. One method they've used is to give money to volunteers and tell them to spend it either on themselves or on others. Social psychologist Liz Dunn says most people expect, no surprise, to get more happiness from spending the money on themselves.
会计在慈善捐款那一栏停了下来。作为一个深谙慷慨之心理学益处相关文献的人，你的会计是不是担心你捐掉的钱太多了？他并不担心我捐的钱太多。他读过关于我的研究的文章——你知道的，把你的工作显著呈现在媒体上的缺点就是你的会计也会读到它。所以当他看到我纳税申报表上的慈善捐款栏时，他向我投来了一种眼神，仿佛在说：
And you know, it's kind of interesting because I do get letters from people saying, you know, why did scientists need to come along and do this research like this idea of helping others as in the Bible or my mom told me this. But the interesting thing is that when you bring money into the picture, people just don't seem to realize that that $20 bill in their pocket might be better spent on somebody else than on themselves. So some years ago you were sitting down with an accountant and going over your taxes,
我一眼就看穿了你灵魂中最赤裸、最丑陋的部分。你还在告诉所有人，把钱捐出去会让他们多么快乐。但老实说，这并不让人印象深刻。你捐的钱其实并不算多。这真的让我印象深刻，你知道的，作为一个清算的时刻，我当时想：“天哪，好吧，我真的需要做得更好才行。”
and the accountant stops on the line that talks about your charitable contributions. As someone steeped in the literature on the psychological benefits of generosity, was your accountant worried that you were giving away too much of your money? He was not worried that I was giving away too much money. He had read about my research, you know, the downside of having your work prominently featured in the media is that your accountant reads about it. And so when he saw the charitable giving line of my tax return, he shot me this look of like,
然后会计师停在了谈论你慈善捐款的那一行。作为一名深入研究慷慨带来的心理益处的研究者，你的会计师曾担心你捐出太多钱吗？他并不担心我捐出太多钱。他读过我的研究，你知道的，工作成果被媒体大肆报道的一个坏处就是你的会计师也会看到。所以当他看到我纳税申报单上的慈善捐款那一栏时，他向我投来了一种眼神，仿佛在说，
I see through you to the barest, ugliest part of your soul. And you're telling everybody else, oh, happy it would make them to give money away. But like, this is not impressive. How much money you're giving away. And I really like stood out to me, you know, as this like moment of reckoning, I was like, oh God, okay, I really need to be doing better.
我一眼就看穿了你灵魂最赤裸、最丑陋的部分。而你却在告诉其他人，哦，捐钱会让他们多么快乐。但听着，这根本不令人印象深刻，你捐了多少钱。这真的让我印象深刻，你知道的，作为一个清算的时刻，当时我想，天哪，好吧，我真的需要做得更好。
Why were you not practicing what you were preaching Liz? And what would happen when you tried? Well, you know, I would give money to charities here and there. And one thing that I was really wrestling with is that I wasn't getting much of an emotional boost from these giving experiences that I was having, which was really puzzling to me because, you know,
Liz，你为什么没有践行自己宣扬的理念呢？当你尝试时又会发生什么？嗯，你知道的，我会零星地给慈善机构捐款。我当时真正纠结的一点是，这些捐赠经历并没有给我带来太多的情感提升，这让我感到非常困惑，因为，你知道的，
we saw that even in parts of the world where people were struggling to meet their own basic needs, giving money to charity was linked to greater happiness. So I was like, what is wrong with me? Why am I not feeling this emotional boost that all of my research suggests should be there? And you started to ask yourself, is there something wrong in the literature or is there something wrong with you? Yeah, and so, you know, maybe there is something wrong with me, but I guess my first inclination was to explore whether we'd miss something in the research.
我们看到，甚至在世界上人们难以满足自身基本需求的地区，向慈善机构捐款也与更高的幸福感息着相。所以我当时就在想，我到底怎么了？为什么我没有感受到我所有的研究都表明应该存在的情感提升？你当时开始问自己，是文献出了问题，还是你自身出了问题？是的，所以，你知道的，也许是我自身有什么问题，但我想我的第一反应是去探讨我们是否在研究中遗漏了什么。
So maybe it's not the case that giving to charity always makes people happier. Maybe it actually depends how you do it. So maybe I was just doing it wrong. And so I started with my colleagues and students exploring when people get the biggest emotional boost from giving to charity. And when that emotional boost seems to sort of disappear. You ran a study where you asked people to give money to UNICEF. Tell me what UNICEF does and what the experiment was about.
所以也许向慈善机构捐款并不总是让人更快乐。也许这实际上取决于你如何去做。所以也许我只是方法不对。因此，我和同事及学生们开始探讨，人们在什么时候从向慈善机构捐款中获得的情感提升最大，以及这种情感提升在什么时候似乎会某种程度上消失。你做了一项研究，要求人们向联合国儿童基金会捐款。请告诉我联合国儿童基金会是做什么的，以及这个实验是关于什么的。
Yeah, so UNICEF is a wonderful charity that really helps to support children's health initiatives around the world. But UNICEF is such a big broad charity that it can be a little hard to really envision how your own small donation is going gonna really make a difference. So we asked people to give money to either UNICEF or another charity called Spread the Net.
是的，联合国儿童基金会是一个非常棒的慈善机构，它切实帮助支持世界各地的儿童健康倡议。但联合国儿童基金会是一个如此庞大而广泛的慈善机构，以至于很难真正想象你自己的小额捐款将如何真正发挥作用。因此，我们要求人们向联合国儿童基金会或另一个名为“传播网络”（Spread the Net）的慈善机构捐款。
And what does Spread the Net do and what's the difference between their approach and the UNICEF approach? So Spread the Net has a lot in common with UNICEF. They're actually partners. They both care about promoting children's health. But Spread the Net has a very clear and specific mission And so what they do is that for every ten dollars donated
“传播网络”是做什么的？他们的运作方式与联合国儿童基金会的方法有什么区别？“传播网络”与联合国儿童基金会有很多共同点。他们实际上是合作伙伴。他们都关心促进儿童健康。但“传播网络”有一个非常清晰且具体的使命，所以他们做的是，每捐赠十美元，
They purchased one bed net to protect a child from malaria So if you make even a small donation to this charity you have a very clear idea of how you're making a difference So we chose these charities because you know both important, worthwhile, working kind of the same general space, but spread the net is giving donors a very clear window into how their dollars are making a difference. Whereas with UNICEF, it can just be a bit harder to really understand how your donation is really going to change anyone's life. So in other words, when you're asking people to give it's really
他们就会购买一个蚊帐来保护儿童免受疟疾侵害。因此，如果你向这个慈善机构进行哪怕是很小的捐赠，你也会非常清楚地知道自己是如何发挥作用的。我们选择这些慈善机构是因为，你知道的，两者都很重要、很有价值，在同一种大体相同的领域工作，但“传播网络”为捐赠者提供了一个非常清晰的窗口，让他们了解自己的美元是如何发挥作用的。而在联合国儿童基金会，要想真正理解你的捐赠将如何真正改变某人的生活，可能会稍微困难一些。换句话说，当你要求人们捐款时，
helpful that they know what their money is getting, that the more specific feedback that you can give them about the good that their money is doing, the greater the likelihood that their generosity is going to give them a warm glow and the greater the likelihood that they actually give. Yeah, so people get the biggest emotional boost from giving to others when they can really envision or better yet directly see how their dollars are actually making a difference. So in the case of our spread the net and unicef experiment, what we discovered was that the more money people gave to spread the net, the happier they tended to feel afterward. But kind of remarkably, this emotional boost of giving was eliminated when people gave money to UNICEF. So the suggests
让他们知道自己的钱用在了哪里是非常有帮助的，你给他们的关于他们的钱所做的好事的具体反馈越多，他们的慷慨给他们带来温暖的喜悦的可能性就越大，他们实际捐款的可能性也就越大。是的，当人们能够真正想象或更好的是直接看到他们的美元实际上是如何发挥作用时，他们从向他人捐赠中获得的情感提升最大。因此，在我们的“传播网络”与联合国儿童基金会实验中，我们发现，人们给“传播网络”捐的钱越多，他们事后感到的幸福感往往就越高。但有点引人注目的是，当人们向联合国儿童基金会捐款时，这种捐赠的情感提升就被消除了。所以这表明
that just giving money to a worthwhile charity doesn't automatically inherently trigger this emotional benefit. Instead, it really does seem to matter whether you can have a window into how you're actually having an impact on others' lives. So besides the value of telling people exactly how their money is going to be used and to give them a sense that this is the impact it's going to have, you're also finding that the connection that people have with the object of their generosity seems to matter.
仅仅向一个有价值的慈善机构捐款，并不会自动、固有地触发这种情感益处。相反，你是否能有一个窗口来了解你如何真正对他人的人生生产生影响，这似乎确实至关重要。因此，除了告诉人们他们的钱将如何被精确使用并让他们感受到这将产生的影响这一价值之外，你还发现，人们与他们慷慨对象的联系似乎也很重要。
And I'm wondering if you can tell me a personal story of your involvement with the Syrian refugee crisis and how your work with them has shaped how you've come to understand the psychology of generosity. Yeah, so at the peak of the Syrian refugee crisis when stories about that terrible, terrible crisis were on the cover of the newspaper every day, and we were seeing really just horrifying photos of even young children dying in this crisis, I was overcome with the desire to
我想知道你是否能讲一个关于你参与叙利亚难民危机的个人故事，以及你与他们的工作如何塑造了你对慷慨心理学的理解。是的，在叙利亚难民危机的顶峰时期，关于那场可怕危机的报道每天都占据着报纸的头版，我们看到诸如甚至年幼儿童在那场危机中死去的极其恐怖的照片，我被一种强烈的渴望所淹没，那就是
do something to help. My first inclination was to donate money to big, reputable charities that were doing good work on this issue. And that's exactly what I did. But again, I just didn't feel much of an emotional boost at all from it. I just felt like I wasn't making a difference. And so luckily, I live in Canada. And here in Canada, I discovered we have this incredible program
做点什么来帮忙。我的第一反应是向在这个问题上做着出色工作的各大知名慈善机构捐款。而这正是我的所作所为。但同样，我从中根本没有感受到太多的情感提升。我只是觉得自己并没有发挥什么作用。所以幸运的是，我住在加拿大。在加拿大，我发现我们有一个不可思议的项目
called Group of Five. So the idea of the Group of Five is that any five Canadian citizens can actually privately sponsor a family of refugees, and you have to raise enough money to support the family for their first year in Canada, and then they actually get on a plane to your city. So they moved to your city and you're responsible for them for their first year in Canada. And you know, this is a big undertaking.
叫做“五人组”（Group of Five）。“五人组”的想法是，任何五个加拿大公民都可以私下资助一个难民家庭，你必须筹集足够的资金来支持该家庭在加拿大的第一年，然后他们真的会坐飞机来到你的城市。因此，他们搬到了你的城市，你要对他们在加拿大的第一年负责。你知道的，这是一项巨大的承诺。
And one of the things that I think is so awesome about this program is that no matter how sort of wealthy and connected or smart you might be, you are not allowed to do this alone. And it happened that a bunch of my friends were interested in this as well. So I remember we all got together at someone's house one night and talked through it and thought, you know, is this something that we could do? And by the end of that night, we pretty much decided like, okay, let's try to do this. So the first step was that we
我认为这个项目最棒的一点在于，无论你多么富有、人脉多么广或者多么聪明，你都不被允许独自完成这件事。当时碰巧我的一群朋友对此也很感兴趣。所以还记得有一天晚上我们聚在某个人的家里，讨论了这件事，并心想，你知道的，这是我们能做的事吗？在那天结束时，我们几乎决定了，好吧，让我们试着做这件事。所以第一步就是我们
had to raise the money. So in our case, we had to raise about $40,000. That turned out to really be kind of the easy part because everyone was very concerned about the Syrian refugee crisis at that time and people really opened up their wallets and gave. One of the big challenges, of course, is finding them a house. And so the family that we brought over had five kids,
必须筹集资金。在我们的案例中，我们必须筹集大约40,000美元。事实证明这实际上算是比较容易的部分，因为当时每个人都非常关心叙利亚难民危机，人们真的打开了钱包并慷慨解囊。当然，其中一个巨大的挑战是为他们找房子。所以我们接来的这个家庭有五个孩子，
which is pretty much unheard of in Vancouver. Like in Vancouver, housing is very expensive. Most people have zero, one, or two kids. So that was a huge mission in and of itself. We found them a house, we filled it up with furniture, we stuffed their fridge with some nice fresh food and then before long it was time for us to go to the airport and meet our family. Liz and her friends gathered in an airport waiting room with welcome signs and balloons. And I still think about this moment where the doors are opened from customs and our family of seven walked through those doors. And as soon as they saw us, the father, who's this, you know, very strong, emotionally resilient man, his eyes just filled with tears at seeing us. And, you know, his wife was also quite overcome
这在温哥华几乎是闻所未闻的。就像在温哥华，住房非常昂贵。大多数人有零个、一个或两个孩子。所以这本身就是一个巨大的任务。我们为他们找了一所房子，在里面塞满了家具，在他们的冰箱里塞满了美味的新鲜食物，不久之后，我们就该去机场迎接我们的家庭了。Liz和她的朋友们聚集在一个机场候机室里，手里拿着欢迎标语和气球。我依然在回想那个时刻，海关的大门打开了，我们七口之家穿过了那些门。他们一看到我们，那位父亲——一个你知道的、非常坚强、情感坚韧的男子——看到我们时，眼里立刻充满了泪水。而且，你知道的，他的妻子也禁不住
with emotion. Her sister had come to Canada previously through the same program. So they were with us too. And so we got to see these two sisters be reunited after being separated for 15 years. So we got to be there for that moment where these two women came back together. And that experience, it still gives me chills now and I think about it. And it's, you know, so far removed from the experience of going onto a website and donating money to charity and hoping that it makes a difference for somebody at some point, right? In this moment, you know, we could see everything that our group had contributed
情绪激动。她的姐姐之前通过同一个项目来到了加拿大。所以他们也和我们在一起。因此我们得以见证这两姐妹在分别15年后重新团聚。所以我们得以亲历这两个女人重新聚在一起的那一刻。那种经历，现在想起来依然让我起鸡皮疙瘩。而且，你知道的，这与去网站向慈善机构捐款并希望它在某个时候对某人有所帮助的体验相去甚远，对吧？在这个时刻，你知道的，我们可以看到我们团队贡献的一切
really reshaping the lives of this whole family. I'm struck that you use the phrase, our family, when you describe this, this Syrian family that came in. I mean, at this point, this is not just a them that you're helping. This is an us that you're helping. at this point, this is not just a them that you're helping, this is an us that you're helping. Yeah, and so when we when we first took on this project, we would always just refer to the refugees, which I think is the way that most people talk about refugees, right? And now it sounds so weird to me to refer to them as the refugees, right? Because I think from the moment that they walked through the doors at the Vancouver Airport, like the children in this family just climbed into my heart. They'll just be there forever. And yeah, so it's a really
真正重塑了整个家庭的生活。我印象深刻的是，当你描述这个来到这里的叙利亚家庭时，你用了“我们的家庭”这个词。我的意思是，在这一点上，这不仅仅是你们在帮助的“他们”。这是你们在帮助的“我们”。在这一点上，这不仅仅是你们在帮助的“他们”，这是你们在帮助的“我们”。是的，所以当我们第一次承接这个项目时，我们总是把他们简称为“难民”，我认为这是大多数人谈论难民的方式，对吧？现在，把他们称为“难民”对我来说听起来太奇怪了，对吧？因为我认为从他们走过温哥华机场大门的那一刻起，这个家庭的孩子们就直接走进了我的心底。他们将永远留在那里。所以，这是一个
amazing experience to know that you have been able to alter the course of life for a whole family. After we met them at the airport, we got to take them to their new home. We got to play soccer with them in the front yard, show the kids their bedrooms. One of my friends, my friend Kylie, had brought her daughter over a week or two earlier, and together they had decorated the girl's bedroom to try to make it just the way a preteen girl would want it. So basically we'd put quite a bit of thought into trying to create not just this house for them, but create this home for them. And this feeling of being able to say to them, your home, you know, this is your place now.
非常美妙的体验，知道自己能够改变一个家庭的人生轨迹。我们在机场接到他们后，把他们带到了他们的新家。我们在前院和他们一起踢足球，带孩子们参观他们的卧室。我的一个朋友，我的朋友Kylie，在一两周前把她的女儿带了过去，她们一起装饰了女孩的卧室，试图把它装饰成一个前青春期女孩想要的模样。所以基本上我们花了不少心思，不仅为他们建造了这所房子，还为他们创造了这个家。并且拥有这种能够对他们说“你们的家，你知道的，这里现在是你们的地方”的感觉，
And certainly the most profoundly rewarding experience of my life. So, when you had this group come together, the Canadian government requires that at least five families come together, but I understand that you actually built a larger group. Tell me about that group and tell me about the dynamics in that group before this family came over. I'm imagining that actually this was a source of bonding for the group itself, that in other words, you were establishing ties with the one another,
这无疑是我一生中最深刻、最有回报的体验。所以，当你们把这个群体聚在一起时，加拿大政府要求至少有五个家庭聚在一起，但我了解到你们实际上建立了一个更大的群体。跟我讲讲那个群体，以及在这个家庭到来之前该群组内部的动态。我想象实际上这也是该群体本身凝聚力的来源，换句话说，你们在彼此之间建立联系，
separate from the ties that you were establishing with this Syrian family that you were bringing over. Absolutely. So, in the end, there were more than 25 people involved in our group, and about six or seven of us who were very deeply involved. And we were constantly having to sort of overcome challenges, problem solved together. You know, one of the things that I loved about this experience is that I really got to see my friends' strengths.
这不同于你们与要迎接到来的这个叙利亚家庭所建立的联系。绝对是的。所以，最后有超过25人参与了我们的群体，其中大约有六七个人非常深入地参与其中。我们不得不不断地克服挑战、共同解决问题。你知道的，我非常喜欢这种经历的一点是，我真正看到了我朋友们的长处。
So most of the people that I was working with closely on this project, I already cared about I was already good friends with, but I hadn't necessarily seen everything they were capable of. So, you know, one of my friends, for example, is a nurse and she can just take over any situation, get everything under control, and like fix whatever is going wrong. And she just amazed me time and time again
因此，我在这个项目上与之密切合作的大多数人，我本来就很在乎他们，也已经是好朋友了，但我未必见识过他们所能做到的一切。所以，你知道的，例如我的一个朋友是一名护士，她可以接管任何情况，让一切重回正轨，并解决任何出错的事情。在这个过程中，她一次又一次地让我惊叹
through this process. Like I just got to see these strengths of hers that, you know, in our casual sort of day to day friendship, I hadn't got into experience. So it's so interesting because the difference here is not just between, you know, writing a check and helping a family. I mean, just in terms of financial help, I'm guessing you probably have donated far more financially than you would have ever written in a check to any organization, just not just in terms of time, but just in terms of the resources you're giving this family or the help you're giving this family. Essentially,
就像我得以见识到她的这些长处，你知道的，在我们日常随意的友谊中，我还没机会体验到。这太有趣了，因为这里的区别不仅仅在于，你知道的，开一张支票和帮助一个家庭。我的意思是，仅就经济帮助而言，我猜你实际在财务上的捐赠远比你曾经给任何组织开过的支票要多得多，不仅仅是时间的投入，而且就你给予这个家庭的资源或你给予这个家庭的帮助而言。本质上，
you've essentially had an open checkbook as you're working with this family, but it's also, you're not even thinking about the money it sounds like, because at this point, you're not actually helping someone else. You're actually helping them as if you were to help your own family members. You're not thinking of it as an act of generosity. You're just saying, this is what it means to be Liz. Yeah, and I think this was something that really struck all of our group members is that once our family arrived, it just seemed obvious that we were just gonna do whatever they needed. We were just gonna, you know, whatever problem arose,
你在与这个家庭合作时基本上拥有了一张支票簿，但这也是，听起来你甚至都没有去想钱的事，因为在这个时刻，你实际上并不是在帮助其他人。你实际上是在像帮助你自己的家庭成员一样在帮助他们。你并不认为这是一种慷慨的行为。你只是在说，这就是做Liz的含义。是的，我认为这也是让我们所有团队成员真正感到震撼的一点，那就是一旦我们的家庭到达，很显然我们只是会做他们需要的任何事情。无论出现什么问题，我们都会
we were gonna help them figure it out. You know, again and again, I've been just stunned by the level of generosity that my group members have shown not only in terms of the financial support, but also, you know, my friend Mandy dropped all of the work that she was doing one day when the family needed to go to a clinic and, you know, needed her help in getting there and in navigating that system. And the oldest kid in the family who was 13 when he arrived, he just kept saying, I just wanna be on a soccer team. And so one of my friends was able to find a team even though it was the middle of the season. She found a coach who was willing to add a last minute player
帮他们弄清楚。你知道的，一次又一次，我的团队成员所表现出的慷慨水平让我震惊，不仅是在财政支持方面，而且，你知道的，有一天当家人需要去诊所并且需要她的帮助去那里以及在那个系统中导航时，我的朋友Mandy放弃了她正在做的所有工作。这个家庭里最大的孩子到达时13岁，他一直说，我只想加入一个足球队。因此，尽管正值赛季中期，我的一个朋友还是设法找到了一支球队。她找到了一位教练，愿意接纳一个刚刚来到加拿大的
who had just arrived in Canada. And I just remember seeing him kind of running onto the soccer field and, you know, getting high fives from these teammates who were opening up their team to him. People have just been ready to sort of drop what they're doing and help this family. And I think that, too, has really just increased the depth of my relationship with my close friends who've been involved in this because I've just seen the best side of their humanity. Elizabeth Dunn is a social psychologist at the University of British Columbia.
最后一刻才加入的球员。我只记得看到他奔跑着冲上足球场，你知道的，并得到了这些向他敞开怀抱的队友们的击掌祝贺。人们随时准备放下手中的事情来帮助这个家庭。我认为，这也确实加深了我与参与其中的密友的关系，因为我看到了他们人性中最美好的一面。Elizabeth Dunn是英属哥伦比亚大学的社会心理学家。
Along with Michael Norton, she's the author of Happy Money, the Science of Happier Spending. Liz, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
她与Michael Norton合著了《快乐钱：快乐消费的科学》（Happy Money, the Science of Happier Spending）。Liz，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢邀请我。由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Hidden Brain listener and supporter, Christian Lee. Christian tells us that she started listening to the show about two years ago. She was drawn in by an episode we did about identical twins. She writes, I was hooked from that point on. Now you can find me listening when I run, when I drive, when I clean, when I'm getting ready for work in the morning. Pretty much anytime I have a spare moment. We're so happy to be a part of your daily routines, Christian. Thank you for listening and for your support. If you'd like to join Christian in helping to bring more episodes of Hidden Brain to life,
我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是《隐藏的大脑》的听众和支持者Christian Lee。Christian告诉我们，她大约在两年前开始收听这个节目。她被我们制作的一期关于同卵双胞胎的节目所吸引。她写道，从那时起我就迷上了。现在你可以在我跑步时、开车时、打扫卫生时、早晨准备上班时听到我的节目。几乎在我有空闲时间的任何时候。Christian，我们非常高兴能成为你日常生活的一部分。感谢你的收听和支持。如果你想和Christian一样，帮助将更多《隐藏的大脑》节目带入生活，
please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. That site again is support.hiddenbrain.org. Next week we conclude our Happiness 2.0 series with a look at an emotion that can be both exhilarating and destabilizing and the profound effects it has on our mental and physical health. You just share more when you're feeling awe, you cooperate more, you give more, just with a minute or two of looking it up at some trees. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。网址再次是 support.hiddenbrain.org。下周我们将结束“幸福2.0”系列，探讨一种既令人兴奋又具破坏性的情绪，以及它对我们心理和身体健康的深远影响。当你感到敬畏时，你会分享更多，你会更多地合作，你会付出更多，只需花上一两分钟抬头看看树木。我是Shankar Vedantam。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。